hey this is pressure Locker start with a
3x3 grid of squares where each square
has a side length of four draw an arc of
one quarter circle then draw another arc
of another quarter circle draw a third
arc of another quarter circle and
finally draw a fourth arc of a quarter
circle these arcs bound a region the
question is what is the area of the
shaded region remember the figure
involves squares and quarter circles
this problem was asked to students in
Singapore can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
I'm going to present two different
solutions in this video the first
solution I'm going to present to you is
going to be much more complicated but
I'm going to show it to you so that
you'll appreciate the elegant and clever
solution that I'm going to present after
it so here's how I approach the problem
I started out by considering the area of
this quarter circle I said I could get
to the area of the shaded region by
subtracting out the areas of different
regions I could subtract out the areas
of two squares I would get rid of the
area of this triangle I would then get
rid of this area which is the region
between square and a quarter circle then
I would need to get rid of this segment
of a circle and finally I would need to
get rid of this segment of the circle so
I can write an equation for the shaded
region as follows I start out with the
area of a quarter of a circle I then
subtract out the area of two squares and
a triangle and then I subtract out some
of these segments and sectors which are
related to a circle I'll write some of
the dimensions for these shapes so that
I know how to calculate it once I write
the formulas for the different areas so
the area of a quarter circle is equal to
PI R squared divided by four
this quarter-circle involves a radius of
12 so this has an area of 36 pi the area
of a square is equal to its side length
squared so these two squares have an
area of 16 each the area of an isosceles
right triangle is equal to its side
squared divided by 2 this triangle has
an area of 8 now this blue region is the
area between a square and 1/4 of a
circle this will have an area that's
equal to R squared minus PI R squared
divided by 4 here R equals 8 so this
blue region has an area of 64 minus 16
pi the area of a segment of a circle is
equal to 1/4 the circle minus a triangle
here we have quarter circles so it's 1/4
of a circle minus the area of an
isosceles right triangle this will be
equal to PI R squared divided by 4 minus
R squared over 2 we can compute the
areas of these segments of circles so we
figured out all the areas that we need
we now need to go through and add and
subtract appropriately and we'll get to
our answer that the area of the shaded
region is equal to 32 PI minus 64 so
this method does work but it does
involve a lot of calculations and you
could see there's possibly a room for
miscalculation by getting some of the
subtractions and additions confused so
let's try and figure out this problem in
a much more direct way so I found out
there's a very elegant solution this
problem and involves understanding some
of the symmetry first draw a diagonal to
this rect this grid of squares we now
have a lower segment and an upper
segment in the shaded region what we're
going to do is we're going to join them
together we'll take this upper segment
of the shaded region and we're going to
rotate it across this diagonal
we're going to join it together when we
remove the lines from these previous
quarter circles we now end up with
another representation of the area of
the shaded region this will be equal to
one segment of a circle minus another
segment of a circle in other words the
area of the shaded region is equal to
the area of this segment of a circle
minus the area of this segment of the
circle the area of each of these
segments of a circle for one quarter of
a circle we can write out as equaling
one quarter of a circle minus the area
of the triangle this will be PI R
squared divided by four minus R squared
over two we can use the different values
for the radius of these to figure out
the first is equal to 36 pi minus 72 and
the second is equal to 4 pi minus 8 and
now we can directly get to the answer of
32 pi minus 64 did you figure out the
answer and did you come across the
clever method thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch around my blog mind your
decisions that you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch around social media at pressure
soccer and please check out my books
their links in the video description